Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. From very early youth, I had brooded about soldiers and war, and often I had imagined, in dreams and daydreams,
感谢收听《历史的 restis》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的 restis》。想要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告音频并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您在使用 Apple Podcasts 应用，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。从极早的少年时期起，我就一直在思索士兵与战争，我经常在梦想和白日梦中想象，
the sensations attendant upon being for the first time under fire. It seemed to my youthful mind that it must be a thrilling and immense experience to hear the whistle of bullets all around, and to play at hazard from moment to moment with death and wounds. Moreover, now that I had assumed professional obligations in the matter, I thought that it might be as well to have a private rehearsal, a secluded trial trip, in order to make sure that the ordeal was not one
初次经历炮火洗礼时所伴随的感觉。在年少的心灵看来，听到四处呼啸的子弹，随时在生死和负伤之间进行命运的博弈，一定是一次惊心动魄而又无比宏大的体验。此外，既然我在这个问题上已经承担了职业责任，我想不妨先进行一次私下排练，一次隐秘的试航，以确保这场考验并非我这种
unsuited to my temperament. Accordingly, it was to Cuba that I turned my eyes. That, Dominic, was yet again a brilliant, brilliant impression of Winston Churchill. Ever less comprehensible
性格所不能承受的。于是，我将目光投向了古巴。多米尼克，那又是一次精彩绝伦的温斯顿·丘吉尔模仿秀。越来越难以理解
your church but he if you listen to him he is pretty incomprehensible so for this i did actually bother to listen to how he spoke rather than just you know this kind of fantasy impression which i done before and actually he is quite pretty incomprehensible and he has a speech impediment and yes of course i thought that was, I mastered the impression there. Master the impersonation. No, because you sound too clear. You sound too clear.
你的丘吉尔了，但是如果你听他说话，他其实相当难以理解。所以为此我实际上费了一番功夫去听他是怎么说话的，而不仅仅是你懂的，我以前做过的那种奇幻模仿，实际上他相当难以理解，他有言语障碍，是的，当然我认为那是，我在那里掌握了这个模仿。掌握了模仿。不，因为听起来太清晰了。你听起来太清晰了。
So the whole point of this, dear listeners, is that we are in part two of our survey of the early life of Winston Churchill and Dominic in part one, we looked at his family background, his childhood, his education. So in 1894, in December, he passed out of Sandhurst. He'd come 20th out of his class of 150. That's not bad. And then the following month, 24th of January, 1895, his father, Lord Randolph Churchill, dies. And we talked in part one about how Churchill hero worshipped his father lord randolph churchill dies and we talked in part one about how churchill hero
所以亲爱的听众们，这一切的重点在于，我们正处于对温斯顿·丘吉尔早年生活审视的第二部分，而在第一部分中，多米尼克，我们探讨了他的家庭背景、童年和教育。因此在 1894 年 12 月，他从桑赫斯特毕业了。在 150 人的班级中，他名列第 20。这还不错。然后第二个月，即 1895 年 1 月 24 日，他的父亲伦道夫·丘吉尔勋爵去世了。我们在第一部分中讨论过丘吉尔是如何盲目崇拜他的父亲的伦道夫·丘吉尔勋爵去世了，我们在第一部分中讨论过丘吉尔是如何盲目
worshipped his father but how his father was was basically i mean a monster i mean a terrible man and a terrible parent so in a way do you think this is a kind of liberation for him or does it just intensify that that desire to to demonstrate his worth to the shade the now the the departed shade of his father? That's a good question, Tom. I'm not sure. I don't, I think, I mean, that's pure amateur sort of psychology, isn't it?
崇拜他的父亲的，但他的父亲基本上——我的意思是，是个怪物，一个可怕的人和糟糕的家长。所以在某种程度上，你认为这对他来说是一种解脱，还是只会加剧那种渴望，去向父亲那个如今已经逝去的幻影证明自己的价值？这是一个好问题，汤姆。我不太确定。我不，我认为，我的意思是，那是纯粹的业余心理分析，对吧？
I think- Well, you know I love a bit of cold psychology. I know, but I do too. Of course, we all do when we look at historical figures and Churchill, not least. I think it must have been in some sense a liberation. I mean, Churchill's not going to get any more letters from his father telling him he's a mere social wastrel anymore. But on the other hand, Churchill, the hero worship of his father never lessens.
我认为——好吧，你知道我喜欢一点冷冰冰的心理分析。我知道，但我也喜欢。当然，当我们审视历史人物时，我们所有人都会这么做，丘吉尔尤其如此。我认为在某种意义上这一定是一种解脱。我是说，丘吉尔不会再收到他父亲的信，指责他是个无用的社会败类了。但另一方面，丘吉尔对父亲的盲目崇拜从未减弱。
I mean, if anything, it intensifies. I mean, years and years later, his friend Violet Asquith said of him, he worshipped at the altar of his unknown father and Churchill does things like you know he will sort of carry his father's old dispatch boxes or he'll dress up in his father's old robes or he he consciously kind of copies his father's mannerisms he puts his hand on his hip in exactly the same way that his father did deliberately wears his father's robes as Chancellor of the Exchequer, calls his son Randolph. So his father is in a sense, is he liberated? I don't know. I mean, his father is in a sense always on his shoulder, I think, or this fantasy image of his father anyway, that he feels he has to live up to. But that quotation that you started with, that Churchill on war, I mean mean that's something that we would find
我的意思是，如果有的话，它反而加剧了。多年以后，他的朋友维奥莱特·阿斯奎斯曾这样评价他：他在他那位不为人知的父亲的祭坛前顶礼膜拜。丘吉尔会做一些事情，比如他会带着他父亲的旧公文包，或者穿上他父亲的旧长袍，或者他会有意识地模仿他父亲的习惯动作，他把手放在臀部上的姿势和他的父亲完全一样，作为财政大臣时故意穿上父亲的长袍，把儿子命名为伦道夫。因此，在某种程度上，他的父亲——他解脱了吗？我不知道。我的意思是，在某种程度上，他父亲的身影似乎总是萦绕在他心头，或者至少是他心中那个父亲的幻影，他觉得必须达到那个高度。然而，你一开始提到的那段引语，丘吉尔对战争的看法，我的意思是，那是我们会发现
most people now would find very unsettling and indeed later on so they build up to the first world war lots of sort of liberal politicians churchill was a liberal would say of churchill there was something sinister about his bloodthirstiness and his his you know his fascination with war how much he enjoys it how much he thinks it's all a game. And I think Churchill had, to a degree that was unusual, even by the standards of the 1890s, an obsession with adventure, didn't he? I mean, he really, life to him is one long Indiana Jones. But it's not necessarily adventure for adventure's sake, is it?
现在大多数人会觉得非常不安，事实上，在后来的岁月里，当他们为第一次世界大战做准备时，许多自由派政客——丘吉尔曾是一名自由派——会这样评价丘吉尔：他的嗜血和他的——你懂的——他对战争的痴迷，以及他有多么享受战争，认为这不过是一场游戏，这一切背后有着某种阴暗的东西。我认为丘吉尔对冒险有一种痴迷，这种痴迷即使以 1890 年代的标准来看也是不同寻常的，对吧？我的意思是，对他来说，生活真的就像是一场漫长的印第安纳·琼斯冒险。但这并不一定是为了冒险而冒险，对吧？
It's adventure for amplifying his fame, for making a name for himself, and that he can then leverage to have the kind of career that he feels to engage in the cult of psychologising would impress his father. Yes, I'm sure that's right. And of course, his mother, with whom he now starts to have a much, I mean, they're not close, but he writes letters to his mother and his mother actually deigns to reply yes so he's well he's financially dependent on his mother i mean they're both they that that he's he's slightly straightened actually they're the classic sort of aristocratic family that would appear enormously rich yeah as it were social inferiors but actually are struggling the whole time to keep up the kind of show that they need.
这是为了扩大他的名气，为自己扬名，然后他可以利用这一点来谋求他所认为的、能够打动他父亲的那种职业生涯——如果去搞那种心理分析狂热的话。是的，我相信是这样的。当然，还有他的母亲，他现在开始与母亲建立起一种——我的意思是，他们并不亲密，但他会给母亲写信，而他的母亲竟然屈尊回复了。所以他——好吧，他在经济上依赖母亲。我的意思是，他们俩，他们处于那种——实际上他们有些捉襟见肘，他们是典型的贵族家庭，在那些社交地位不如他们的人看来似乎极其富有，
They have an income of 3,000 and they spend 6,000. Yeah, that's right. You have to be Mr. McCorver to realise that that can generate problems. Well, Churchill is incredibly extravagant. He's always extravagant. I mean, anyone who knows anything about him before he becomes prime minister knows that
仿佛富可敌国，但实际上他们一直在苦苦支撑，维持着他们所需的门面。他们的收入是 3,000 英镑，但他们花 6,000 英镑。是的，没错。你得是麦考伯先生才能意识到这会产生问题。好吧，丘吉尔极其奢侈。他一直都很奢侈。我的意思是，任何了解他在成为首相之前的情况的人都知道，
Clemmie, his wife, was always upbraiding him about spending ludicrous sums of money on champagne and cake and all these kinds of things. And Churchill always says, well, you have to do it. And that's because, of course, he's in this late Victorian Edwardian world in which ostentatious display is a crucial part of your status. Anyway, the war stuff, Churchill has this almost, it really is a kind of schoolboy's fantasy image of war. And the classic example of that is, as you say, to Cuba. four thazars which are very dashing you know all those jackets or you know fabulous stuff but he's not content with that because the four thazars are clearly not going to war and so in a way that i
他的妻子克莱门蒂娜总是责备他在香槟、蛋糕之类的事情上挥霍荒谬的巨款。而丘吉尔总是说，好吧，你不得不这么做。这是因为，当然，他身处那个晚期维多利亚和爱德华时代的世界，在这个世界里，炫耀性的展示是你地位的关键部分。无论如何，关于战争的事，丘吉尔对战争有一种近乎——这真的可以说是小学生对战争的奇幻想象。而其中的经典例子就是，正如你所说，去古巴。四名骠骑兵，非常潇洒，你知道，所有那些夹克，或者说那些了不起的东西，但他并不满足于此，因为这四名骠骑兵显然不会去打仗，所以以一种我
don't entirely understand how this works he he parks that and goes off as a war correspondent to cuba where the the americans are fighting the spanish well he has a period of leave but it seems odd that he's just got commissioned. And then he immediately, you know, a few months later, he gets leave to go off to be a war correspondent. I mean, it seems an odd pairing of careers. Yeah, but he's not going primarily as a war correspondent, he's going as a military observer. So he's got 10 weeks leave. And most people, most of his sort of aristocratic contemporaries will spend that time fox hunting because it's the fox hunting season. Churchill, because of that issue that you said about the funds, he doesn't have enough money to buy the horses
并不完全理解其运作方式的方式，他把这事搁在一边，作为战地记者去了古巴，当时美国人正在那里与西班牙人作战。好吧，他有一段假期，但作为一个刚刚获得军衔的人，他紧接着就去当战地记者，这似乎有点奇怪。我的意思是，这两种职业的搭配显得很奇特。是的，但他去那里主要不是作为战地记者，而是作为军事观察员。所以他有 10 周的假期。大多数人，他那些贵族同龄人大多会把时间花在猎狐上，因为那是猎狐季。丘吉尔由于我们刚才提到的资金问题，他没有足够的钱买马
and all the sort of stuff that he needs for that. So he's looking for something to do. And in those days, the British army, they actually encouraged you if you were an aristocratic officer and you said, I'd like to go and have a look at a war. They said, oh, spend it on me. It's a bit like sort of resting football managers who say, oh, I go and spend a few months with Barcelona to watch their training.
以及诸如此类他需要的东西。所以他在寻找事情可做。在那个年代，如果你是一个贵族军官，并且说“我想去看看战争”，英国军队其实会鼓励你。他们会说，哦，去吧。这有点像现在的足球教练说，“哦，我要去巴塞罗那待几个月观察他们的训练”。
This is basically what Churchill's doing. He literally looks at the sort of map and says, there's a war in Cuba, and off he goes. And it's actually not the Americans. So the Americans are yet to get involved in Cuba. So it's guerrillas, it's local sort of independence fighters who are fighting the Spanish authorities. And as you say, the war correspondence is a means to pay for this. So
这基本上就是丘吉尔在做的事。他 literalmente（字面意思）看了一眼地图，说古巴有一场战争，然后他就出发了。而实际上那并不是美国人。美国人当时还没有介入古巴。所以那是游击队，是当地的一些独立战士在与西班牙当局作战。正如你所说，战地记者是支付这趟行程费用的手段。所以
Churchill basically gets it through his mum. So Jenny pays for his ticket to go to America. His father had once written for the Daily Graphic. And so Churchill basically manages to catch a deal that he will file dispatches from Cuba for the Daily Graphic. So off he goes to New York and actually has an encounter in New York that's really important and not much known. So he stays with this bloke who's an old sort of flame or an admirer of Jenny's, who's called Burke Cochran, who's now utterly unknown and forgotten. He was an American congressman who kept changing parties. He was a Democrat for a lot of the time, but then he would walk out of the Democrats and join other little parties and then come back to the Democrats. So he's a real showman in New York politics.
丘吉尔基本上是通过他妈妈搞定的。珍妮支付了他去美国的船票。他父亲曾经为《每日画报》撰稿。因此，丘吉尔基本上成功谈妥了一笔交易，他将为《每日画报》发回来自古巴的战地电报。于是他动身前往纽约，并在纽约有了一次非常重要但鲜为人知的遭遇。他借住在一个人家里，那是珍妮曾经的一个老追求者或仰慕者，名叫伯克·科克兰，这个人现在已经完全默默无闻、被人遗忘了。他曾是一名美国国会议员，不断变换政党。他很长一段时间都是民主党人，但随后又会退出民主党加入其他小政党，接着又回到民主党。所以他是纽约政坛的一个真正的风云人物。
And Churchill adores him and models himself on Bert Cochran to the extent that even some of Churchill's most famous speeches are direct cribs from Bert Cochran's speeches. So, for example, Bert Cochran said of the Irish Home Rule Bill, never before in the history of the English-speaking people has there been a victory which was so great a triumph as that attained by Mr. Gladstone. Is that how he spoke? That's not how Bert Cochran spoke, but that's how Churchill spoke. Churchill, of course, copies that line and uses it about the Battle of Britain. And Churchill admits this.
丘吉尔崇拜他，并以伯克·科克兰为榜样，以至于丘吉尔甚至有些最著名的演讲都是直接抄袭自伯克·科克兰的演讲。例如，伯克·科克兰在谈到爱尔兰地方自治法案时说：“在英语世界的历史上，从未有过像格莱斯顿先生所取得的胜利那样伟大的胜利。”他是那样说话的吗？伯克·科克兰不是那样说话的，但丘吉尔是那样说话的。丘吉尔当然抄袭了这句台词，并把它用在了不列颠战役上。丘吉尔也承认这一点。
He'll say later on, Bert Cochran was my model. I copied everything from him, including flouncing in and out of political parties. But of course, Bert Cochran is now completely forgotten, so nobody cares. And his readiness to model himself on an American politician is also expressive of his broader admiration for America, isn't it? Yeah, he loves America. He loves the energy. He loves the pace, the vigor of it all. Very, very taken by it.
他后来会说：“伯克·科克兰是我的榜样。我从他那里抄袭了一切，包括在政党之间进进出出。”但当然，伯克·科克兰现在已经被彻底遗忘了，所以没有人会在意。而他愿意以一个美国政治家为榜样，这也表达了他对美国更广泛的钦佩，不是吗？是的，他热爱美国。他热爱那里的活力。他热爱那种节奏，那种蓬勃的朝气。他对此着迷不已。
He writes to his brother, Jack, and he says, picture to yourself, the American people is a great lusty youth who treads on all your sensibilities, perpetuates every possible horror of ill manners, but who moves about his affairs with a good hearted freshness, which may well be the envy of the older nations of the earth. Well, good hearted freshness is what Churchill is all about, isn't it? It is actually. I mean, actually, we haven't really sort of stopped for a second. But Churchill at this point, he's a very, very likable character, isn't he? I mean, the good-hearted freshness. I know a lot of people listen to this will maybe be Churchill sceptics and they'll roll their eyes and say, oh, surprise, surprise,
他写信给他的弟弟杰克，他在信中说：“想象一下，美国人民就像一个健壮的青年，他践踏你所有的敏感神经，将所有可能的粗鲁无礼行为发扬光大，但他处理事务时却带着一种好心肠的新鲜感，这足以让地球上古老的国家感到嫉妒。”好吧，这种好心肠的新鲜感正是丘吉尔的写照，对吧？实际上确实如此。我的意思是，其实，我们还没怎么停下来细想过，但在此时此刻，丘吉尔是一个非常非常讨人喜欢的角色，不是吗？我是说，那种好心肠的新鲜感。我知道很多听收听这个节目的人可能会对丘吉尔持怀疑态度，他们会翻着白眼说：“哦，不出所料，
kind of the British history podcasters waxing lyrical about Churchill. But I think if you read My Early Life to this point, it would be very hard to take a dislike to him because he's also so self-aware. He's quite self-mocking. The fun that he had in describing all his sort of scrapes at school and stuff, but also the sort of touching sentimentalism of the way he goes on about his parents who are such monsters. It's a very inimitable mix of deep and unapologetic sentimentality with a profound element of self-awareness. And it's a very peculiar mixture.
英国历史播客的主播们又在对丘吉尔大加赞赏了。”但我认为，如果你读到目前为止的《我的早年生活》，你很难对产生反感，因为他也极具自我意识。他相当自嘲。他把在学校里遇到的各种窘境描述得妙趣横生，但同时，他对那些堪称怪物的父母所表现出的那种感人的伤感主义，又是如此动人。这是一种无可匹敌的组合，将深沉且毫不掩饰的伤感主义与高度的自我意识完美地结合在一起。这是一种非常奇特的混合体。
And I agree, it is very, very likable. One might almost say lovable. Yeah. But with a kind of gunpowder tiggerishness about it that suggests that the whole thing may blow up at any moment. And that, you know, if life is an awfully great adventure, so is death. And Cuba is, I suppose, so he goes to Cuba. So he sails from New York to Cuba. And he has this wonderful passage in his book, My Early Life. He says, when first in the dim light of early morning, I saw the shores of Cuba rise and define themselves
我同意，这非常非常讨人喜欢。甚至可以说有点让人喜爱。是的。但其中又有一种充满火药味的虎虎生气，暗示着这一切随时可能爆炸。而且，你知道，如果生活是一场了不起的伟大冒险，那么死亡也是。古巴就是——我想，他去了古巴。所以他从纽约航行到古巴。他在他的书《我的早年生活》中有一段极妙的描写。他说：“当清晨昏暗的光线中，我第一次看到古巴的海岸从
from dark blue horizons. I felt as if I sailed with Captain Silver and first gazed on Treasure Island. Here was a place where real things were going on. Yeah, and that is a motif that runs throughout his prose, isn't it? Or indeed his comments. He will see war, he will see foreign cities, he will see manifestations of, say, say industrial power and he will compare it to figures from stories so treasure island in that case yeah um later on when he's in the
深蓝色的地平线上升起并显现出轮廓时，我感觉自己仿佛正与西尔弗船长一起航行，第一次凝视着金银岛。这是一个真实的事情正在发生的地方。”是的，这是一个贯穿他所有散文的主题，对吧？或者说贯穿他的评论。每当他看到战争、看到外国城市、看到诸如工业力量之类的表现时，他都会将其与故事中的人物进行对比——在这种情况下就是《金银岛》。是的，嗯，后来当他在
burr war he compares the armored steam trains which will play a key role in his story to knight's errant all that kind of thing he he is always painting the vivid scenes of life in the 1890s in the colors of picture books story books medieval romances and so on and that's clearly not an affectation it's rising from the absolute wellsprings of everything that makes him what he is people often said of churchill later in life that he was terribly immature. They would sort of say that boyishness is immensely annoying and hard. He's impossible to work with. You know,
布尔战争中时，他将那些在他的故事中起到关键作用的装甲蒸汽列车比作游侠骑士，诸如此类。他总是用绘本、故事书、中世纪传奇等色彩来描绘 1890 年代生动的场景，这显然不是一种矫揉造作，而是源于造就他本人的所有特质的绝对源泉。人们后来经常说丘吉尔很不成熟。他们会说那种男孩气极其烦人且难以相处。他根本无法共事。你知道，
he behaves like a, he's a schoolboy trapped in a sort of, in a prime minister's body. And you definitely, that schoolboyishness never, he's never ashamed of it, is he? You know,
他的行为举止就像一个被困在首相躯壳里的小学生。而你绝对会发现，那种小学生气——他从未以此为耻，对吧？你知道，
it's like in its treasure island, which a lot of people would have said maybe at the time, you know's a children's story why are you you know have you not put aside childish things now churchill and he never puts aside childish things he has that sort of irrepressible um almost innocence and it seems a very strange expression to say somebody's going off to watch a war there is a kind of childishness about a lot of the writing of the british empire at this time that you know henty books and yeah rider haggard that imperial adventures are portrayed as as boys adventures and perhaps that's a way of i don't know not avoiding getting drawn into broader, more difficult questions. Dealing with the moral ambiguities.
就像在《金银岛》中一样，当时很多人可能会说，你知道，那是儿童读物，你为什么还要——你难道还没有抛弃幼稚的想法吗？然而丘吉尔从未抛弃幼稚的想法。他拥有那种不可遏制的、几乎是天真无邪的特质。说某人要去“观看战争”听起来是个非常奇怪的说法。那个时期的英国帝国主义写作中有很多类似的孩子气，你知道的，亨蒂的书，还有H·里德·哈格德，帝国的冒险被描绘成男孩们的冒险，也许这是一种方式——我不知道——避免被卷入更广泛、更困难的问题中。处理道德上的模糊性。
The moral ambiguities. Yeah. I mean, these are, you know, this is not Heart of Darkness. This is not, or even some of Kipling's stories of the men who would be king. Now, these are morally less complex narratives that perhaps avoid having to stare into the heart of darkness do you think that's maybe yeah i think there's maybe some truth in it because churchill never really he does have a moral sense as we'll come to when we get to the sudan he does he absolutely does have a sense that you should be sporting i suppose but again the way that he sees it in
道德上的模糊性。是的。我的意思是，这些是——你知道，这不是《黑暗的心》。这不是，甚至也不是吉卜林关于那些想成为国王的人的故事。不，这些是道德上没那么复杂的叙事，也许可以让人避免凝视黑暗的心。你觉得这可能是真的吗？是的，我认为其中可能有些道理，因为丘吉尔从未真正——他确实有道德感，正如我们在讲到苏丹时会看到的，他确实有那种你应当讲究体育精神的意识，我想是的。但再次强调，他以这种方式看待问题，可以说更多地体现了这种幼稚化。
those terms you could say is more of this sort of infantilization. Play up and play the game. Yeah, absolutely. And I think he, the sort of the world is an awfully big adventure. That never, ever leaves him. I mean, even the way, I suppose, if you were being very harsh, you would say even the way he talks about becoming prime minister in 1940, I was walking with destiny. And he sees it as the culmination of what has been coming since he
遵守规则，公平竞争。是的，绝对如此。而且我认为他那种“世界是一场无比宏大的冒险”的想法永远、永远没有离开过他。我的意思是，甚至可以说，如果你说得严厉一点，你会说他连谈到在 1940 年成为首相时也是这样：“我仿佛与命运同行。”他将其视为自
had those schoolboy fantasies i mean he's still the schoolboy in the boarding house talking about saving the empire isn't he we talked about that sense of destiny right at the beginning of part one and perhaps before we we we plunge him into the the drama and excitement of his time in cuba and then after that northwest france and the sud. Perhaps we should talk, dare I say, about his religious beliefs, his understanding of the metaphysical dimension. You've shown tremendous self-restraint, Tom. Well, because Churchill famously said he was like a buttress. He was outside the church supporting it rather than being inside. So he's not really a believer.
他拥有那些小学生幻想以来一切事情的顶峰——我的意思是，他依然是那个在寄宿学校里谈论拯救帝国的男孩，对吧？我们在第一部分刚开始时就谈到了那种宿命感。也许在我们把他投入到他在古巴以及之后的西北边境和苏丹的戏剧与兴奋中之前，我们应该谈谈——我敢说——他的宗教信仰，他对形而上学维度的理解。你表现出了极大的克制，汤姆。好吧，因为丘吉尔曾有一句名言：他就像一根飞扶壁，是在教堂外面支撑着它，而不是身处其中。所以他其实并不是一个真正的信徒。
He's not a believing Christian, but he does have a kind of almost pagan sense of his destiny, his genius, that he's been actually, I mean, rather like Hitler, or perhaps that both of them have this rather strange sense that they've been shaped by destiny for great things. They do believe in a God, but it's not the Christian God. However, the difference between Hitler and Churchill is that Churchill, in his attitude to his moral responsibilities, does seem to have a kind of, you know, a sense of empathy with the underdog. Well, the noblesse oblige that we talked about. Yes, it's an aristocratic sense of responsibility. And of course, he also has this sense that the British have a moral responsibility towards the people that they rule. But perhaps, Dominic, we should come to that when we should look at that question. And the question of how racist was he? I think he was racist when he goes to the Northwest Frontier. But for now, he's in Cuba. And he claimed, didn't he? That he'd heard his first shots fired in anger on his 21st birthday.
他不是一个有信仰的基督徒，但他对自己的命运、自己的天才有一种近乎异教徒般的感知，他实际上——我的意思是，有点像希特勒，或者也许他们俩都有这种相当奇怪的感觉，觉得自己是被命运塑造成大人物的。他们确实相信神，但那不是基督教的神。然而，希特勒与丘吉尔的区别在于，丘吉尔在对待其道德责任的态度上，似乎确实有一种对弱者的同理心。好吧，也就是我们谈过的贵族义务。是的，这是一种贵族式的责任感。当然，他也认为英国人对自己统治的人民负有道德责任。不过，多米尼克，也许我们应该在讨论这个问题时再来谈论它。以及“他有多大程度的种族主义？”这个问题。我认为当他去西北边境时，他是有种族主义的。但现在，他身在古巴。他曾声称，对吧？他在 21 岁生日那天听到了自己打出的第一声充满愤怒的枪响。
In fact, it was the day after. That's classic Churchill. He will, well, I mean, he would shape the narrative, but who doesn't?
事实上，那是第二天。这很典型丘吉尔。他会——我的意思是，他会塑造叙事，但谁又不会呢？
I mean, who, who heard their first shots fired the day after their 21st birthday? You know, smooth that story in and move them a few hours earlier. Of course he does that. So it's the 1st of December, 1895. He's been there just for a few weeks. And what he does is he's hanging around with the Spanish kind of colonial authorities who were trying to put down this uprising that will
我的意思是，谁会在 21 岁生日的第二天听到第一声枪响呢？你知道，把那个故事润色一下，把时间提前几个小时。他当然会这么做。所以那是 1895 年 12 月 1 日。他到那里才几个星期。他做的事就是和西班牙殖民当局混在一起，后者正试图平息这场起义，而这场起义
ultimately lead to the Spanish-American war. And they're just sort of riding around randomly looking for rebels in this sort of very raggedy kind of way and uh they're by a forest and shots ring out the horse next to him is shot in the ribs i mean that would for most people if that happened to you and me tom but that would be the defining moment of our lives yeah i've been talking about that forever the horse next to me this for churchill is just a i mean it's not even a barely even a footnote and he says in a mildly life I could not help reflecting that the bullet which has struck the chestnut horse had certainly passed within a foot of my head so at any rate I'd been under fire that was something
最终将导致美西战争。他们只是漫无目的地骑着马四处搜寻叛军，带着那种非常散漫的态度。他们在森林旁边，枪声突然响起。他身旁的马肋部中弹——我的意思是，如果这种事发生在你我身上，汤姆，那将是我们一生的转折点。是的，我会永远挂在嘴边，我身边的马中弹了。但对丘吉尔来说，这只是一个——我的意思是，甚至连脚注都算不上。他在《我的早年生活》中写道：“我禁不住想，那颗击中栗色马的子弹，绝对是从我头部一英尺的距离内擦过去的。无论如何，我经历过战火了，这总算有些意义。”
yes here we go he's excited by that he's delighted because that's what he's um that's what he's come to see and they sort of ride about a bit and they sort of potter around and they see people shooting the distance but actually he's not really i mean he's there and he's an observer so he's not really in the thick of the action but when he comes back so when he comes back he gets a medal doesn't he gets a medal from the spanish even though red cross of spain he's sympathizing with with the rebels but he has to keep that quiet but he comes back and he can know two things about himself that are going to stand him in very good stead the first is that he is indeed brave under fire that yeah you know he enjoys it so that's something to sort away but also he knows that um he's a his mastery of english prose means that he can write incredibly well so this is great news for his future as a war correspondent
是的，就是这样！他为此感到兴奋，感到高兴，因为这正是他——这正是他来看的东西。他们到处骑了一会儿，慢悠悠地转了转，看到远处有人在开枪，但实际上他并没有——我的意思是，他只是作为一个观察员在那里，所以他并没有真正处于战斗的最前沿。但当他回来时——当他回来时，他获得了一枚勋章，不是吗？他从西班牙人那里获得了一枚勋章，尽管他同情叛军，但他必须对此保持低调。但他回来后，他对自己有了两点认识，这对他未来大有裨益。首先，他在战火中的确很勇敢，是的，你知道，他很享受这种感觉，所以这一点可以记在心里；但同时他也知道，
and that will be a running theme but also tight deadlines all that kind of stuff he's very good journalist but also in the long run of course it will you know he he can know that he can write history and all kinds of other stuff as well so his trip to Cuba teaches him that he has these two you know these two qualities that will serve him in very good stead throughout the rest of his life yeah so he comes back from cuba um as you say he's it's all gone splendidly from that point of view uh he sails with his so he rejoins his regiment and they sail off to um to mumbai to bombay churchill being churchill he he falls off the boat as they're docking and he suffers an injury that again with that anybody else would be a sort of life-defining injury he falls he dislocates his shoulder,
他对英语散文的精通意味着他能写出极佳的文章。这对他的未来作为战地记者来说是个好消息，
and his shoulder from that point onwards is always being dislocated. He's always popping out. So he can never play tennis, for example, a very popular game in the 1890s. He's desperate to play polo, but he always has to play with part of his arm strapped to his body, which is a huge impediment. And actually, it says a great deal about Churchill's ability at polo, that he goes on to play in all kinds of teams and win tournaments and things despite the facts do you score goals in polo he scores loads of is it goals
这将是一个贯穿始终的主题，还有紧迫的截稿日期之类的东西，他是个非常优秀的记者。而且从长远来看，当然，他——他知道自己能写历史以及各种其他题材。因此，他的古巴之行让他明白自己具备这两项——这两项品质将在他的余生中对大有裨益。是的，所以他从古巴回来了——正如你所说，从这个角度来看一切都进行得极其顺利。他与他的——他重新归队，他们乘船前往——前往孟买。丘吉尔不愧是丘吉尔，他们在靠岸时从船上掉了下去，并受了伤。换作任何人，这又会是一个定义人生的伤情。他摔下去，肩膀脱臼了，
is that what you score points or tries or whatever you score in polo anyway he scores them yeah he also um can't use a sword he has to use a pistol so later on in the battle of omdurman um the fact that he's got a pistol stands him in very good stead basically because you know if he wields a sword his arm will fall off okay so um so anyway he gets to bangalore that's the headquarters of the madras presidency and a long way from any action yeah but he was i was, I mean, at that point, there's not that much action going on in India. He's just a post frontier.
而从那时起，他的肩膀就经常脱臼。它总是会掉出来。所以他无法打网球，例如网球是 1890 年代非常受欢迎的运动。他极度渴望打马球，但他总是不得不把手臂的一部分绑在身体上才能打，这是一个巨大的障碍。事实上，这充分说明了丘吉尔在马球方面的能力，尽管有这些事实，他还是继续在各种球队中效力并赢得锦标赛等荣誉。你在马球比赛中能进球吗？他进了大量的——
There's always, well, the Northwest frontier will, will, yeah, that will come. But for the, for the,
那是你得分的方式吗，还是得分、触地得分或其他什么？总之他在马球里得分。是的，他——他还不能用剑，他必须使用手枪。所以在后来的恩图曼战役中，他有一把手枪对他大有裨益，基本上是因为（你知道）如果他挥舞军剑，他的手臂可能会掉下来。好吧，不管怎样，他来到了班加罗尔，那是马德拉斯省的总部，离任何战斗都有相当远的距离。是的，但他在当时，印度其实并没有发生那么多战斗。他只是在一个前哨阵地。
for the time being, he basically spends that first winter reading because he, you know, in the first podcast, we talked about how Churchill, um, had portrayed himself as this dunce to school, which he absolutely wasn't,
那里总是——嗯，西北边境会——会发生的，那将会到来。但目前，
but it's true that he absolutely wasn't. But it's true that he perhaps wasn't quite as well-read as he could have been. But with classic sort of Churchillian sort of dedication, he decides, I'm going to become incredibly well-read. So he starts off by reading Gibbon, Edward Gibbon, very much a friend of the rest of his history, I think it's fair to say. Absolutely a friend of the rest of his history, yeah. And he has this lovely description. If you sort of think, oh, Churchill's greatly overrated,
他基本上把第一个冬天都花在了读书上，因为正如我们在第一期播客中谈到的那样，丘吉尔在学校里把自己塑造成了一个笨蛋，而他绝对不是那样的人，
it's all just sort of smoke and mirrors, you read the way when Churchill in his autobiography, My Early Life, he talks about reading Gibbon. All through the long glistening middle hours of the Indian day, from when we quitted stables to the evening shadows, proclaimed the hour of Polo, I devoured Gibbon. I rode triumphantly through it from end to end and i enjoyed it all and that sort of he absorbs i think gibbon's sense of irony when he
但他的确不是笨蛋。不过，他的阅读量也许确实不如本来可以达到的那样广泛。但凭借典型的丘吉尔式的专注，他决定：“我要让自己变得博览群书。”于是他首先阅读了吉本的著作——爱德华·吉本，可以说是《历史的 restis》的忠实老朋友了。绝对是《历史的 restis》的好朋友，是的。他有一段非常精彩的描写。如果你觉得“哦，丘吉尔被严重高估了，
talks about history his sense of sweep and character his sense that this is a tremendously enjoyable melodrama and and the fact that an english sentence is a noble thing yeah that you can do incredible things with english prose yeah he's given him a corley so macaulay is his other great um his other great love he's gutted that macaulay doesn't think much of the duke of marlborough and i was grieved to read his harsh judgments and uh but then he's funny about macaulay he says there was no one to tell me that this historian with his captivating style and devastating self-confidence was the prince of literary rogues who always preferred the tale to the truth and smirched or glorified great men and
这一切不过是烟幕弹和幻象”，你读读丘吉尔在自传《我的早年生活》中谈到阅读吉本时的文字就知道了：“在印度白昼那漫长而波光粼粼的正午时分，从我们离开马厩，到傍晚的阴影宣告马球时间的到来，我如饥似渴地阅读着吉本。我从头到尾凯旋般地骑马驰骋其中，我享受着这一切。”那种——他吸收了吉本在谈论历史时的反讽感、开阔的视野和对人物的塑造、他认为这是一部极其令人愉悦的情节剧的看法，以及英语句子是一件崇高事物的信念——是的，你可以用英语散文做出不可思议的事情——是的，他还有麦考利。所以麦考利是他另一个挚爱。当他读到麦考利对马尔伯勒公爵评价不高时，他感到痛心疾首，“我读到他严厉的评判时感到很悲伤”，但随后他对麦考利又表现得很幽默，他说：“当时没有人告诉我，这位拥有迷人文风和毁灭性自信的历史学家，其实是文学无赖中的亲王，他总是为了故事而牺牲真相，根据这些伟人对他的戏剧效果的影响，来抹黑或赞美他们，
garbled documents according to how they affected his drama nobody would ever say that of this podcast tom no of course not not not ever uh But my favourite thing about Churchill's kind of autodidacticism, where he's just hoovering up all this stuff that he clearly hadn't read at Harrow, is that he reads Aristotle. He reads Aristotle's Ethics. He says it was very good, but it's extraordinary how much of it I had already thought out for myself. That's what I always think about Greek philosophy, though, Tom. Is that a lot of curtsy when you were 10? mean yeah self-explanatory all this sort of stuff there is a certain harshness perhaps to aristotle's
甚至篡改文件。”汤姆，绝不会有人这样评价这个播客吧？当然不会，绝对不会。不过我最喜欢丘吉尔这种自学成才的劲头的地方在于，他把在哈罗公学显然没读过的那些东西全盘吸收了，他甚至阅读了亚里士多德。他读了亚里士多德的《伦理学》。他说这本书很棒，但令人惊奇的是，其中很大一部分内容他自己早就已经想通了。汤姆，每当我想到古希腊哲学时，我总是有这种感觉。你 10 岁的时候就懂了吗？我是说，是的，不言自明，诸如此类。亚里士多德的《伦理学》中或许确实有一种严苛性，你可以看出这可能会吸引丘吉尔。是的，所以亚里士多德——我的意思是，亚里士多德众所周知地将世界划分为希腊人和野蛮人。他基本上认为希腊人有权统治野蛮人。所以也许这与丘吉尔的思想不谋而合。帝国中有些人对此存有疑虑，被这种优越感所困扰。丘吉尔则没有。好吧，我的意思是，那是一种基督教的推动力，对吧？是的，本质上讲，如果所有人都是按照上帝的形象平等创造的，那么
ethics that you could see might appeal to churchill yeah so aristotle i mean aristotle notoriously defy you know separated the world into Greeks and barbarians. He essentially said that Greeks had the right to rule barbarians. And so perhaps that's something that went with the grain of Churchill's thinking. There are people out in the empire who have doubts about it, who are troubled by the assumption of racial superiority. Churchill doesn't. Well, I mean, that is a christian impetus isn't it yeah essentially i mean if all men are created equally in the image of god then
他们就是平等的。但丘吉尔有一种更具种族主义色彩的观点，认为人类在种族上是有区别的。瞧，我不认为“种族主义”这个词在这里真的很合适。它是没有帮助还是具有误导性？也许两者都有点，
they're equal but churchill has a has a more racist sense of their being that humans are different racially see i don't i think the word racist there is really i is it unhelpful or misleading maybe a bit of both, because we use it to describe a lot of very different things. So there's a kind of racial prejudice, which is, as it were, hateful, which is shot through with resentment and bitterness and sort of a sense of a really sort of horrible sort of sense of disgust and all these kinds of things. I don't think Churchill has that at all. He undoubtedly has something slightly different, I would say, which is an unwavering
因为我们用它来描述许多非常不同的事情。所以存在一种种族偏见，这种偏见可以说是充满敌意的，交织着怨恨、痛苦，以及一种极其糟糕的厌恶感和诸如此类的东西。我认为丘吉尔身上完全没有这种情绪。我可以说，他毫无疑问拥有某种略有不同且坚定不移的
sense of superiority. He doesn't think that other races are horrible or disgusting or brutish. He's actually often quite interested in them. But he just thinks the British are the best. And he loves the empire. It would never occur to him to question the empire. The empire is his creed, his mission. And the way he thinks about it, we talked about his sort of childishness, is a little bit like how a child thinks of, don't you think? Yeah, okay. I do do but i also think that it is and this may be kind of mediated through but i think it's reflective of the darwinian spirit of the age that yeah for the first time has been able to provide a kind of scientific rationale
优越感。他不认为其他种族是可怕的、令人作呕的或野蛮的。他实际上经常对他们相当感兴趣。但他就是认为英国人是最好的。他热爱帝国。质疑帝国是绝对不会进入他的脑海的。帝国是他的信条，他的使命。而他思考帝国的方式——我们讨论过他的孩子气——有点像一个小孩子看待事物的方式，你不觉得吗？是的，好吧。我也这么认为——但这也许是通过某种方式中和了的——但我认为这反映了那个时代的达尔文主义精神，达尔文主义第一次能够为帝国主义者一贯的直觉偏见提供某种科学上的合理性，
for the gut prejudice that imperial peoples have always had that somehow they have won a great empire because they're the best i mean that you know there has never been an imperial people who didn't think that they were the best because they look you know they they look around at their own greatness relative to the people that they rule and say well of course we're best that's that's that's self-evident what darwinism does is to provide what seems to be a scientific explanation for it essentially that different races have evolved at different speeds and therefore some are better than others and i think that churchill i mean whether he's read darwin or
即他们之所以能赢得一个庞大的帝国，是因为他们是最优秀的。我的意思是，（你知道的）历史上从来没有哪个帝国人民不认为自己是最好的，因为他们环顾四周，看到自己相对于他们所统治的人民而言是多么伟大，就会说：“嗯，当然我们是最好的，这是不言而喻的。”达尔文主义所做的，就是为这种现象提供了一个看似科学的解释，本质上就是不同的种族以不同的速度进化，因此有些种族比其他种族更优秀。我认为丘吉尔——不管他有没有读过达尔文，我不知道，也许达尔文是他当年在班加罗尔阅读的一部分，我记不清了——但我认为他只是有着那种本能的假设：环顾帝国的强大与辉煌，我们当然更优秀。但这就好比，你知道他照顾他的保姆，或者一直在——我不知道——给搬运工小费之类的。在丘吉尔看来，英国人对其他种族的关系，就像英国贵族对广大英国底层人民的关系一样。是的，这是一个很好的比较：他们拥有特权，但他们也肩负责任。我想这就是丘吉尔与希特勒的区别所在。
not i don't know maybe he's darwin is part of his reading in bangalore i can't remember yeah but i think that he just has that kind of instinctive assumption look around the might and splendor of the empire of course we're better but it's rather like you know him looking after his nanny he or kept you know tipping i don't know the porter or whatever it the british are to other races in churchill's opinion as the british aristocracy are to the vast mass of the british people yeah that's a good comparison that they have privilege but they also have responsibility. And I guess that that would be the difference between Churchill and Hitler, say.
希特勒对种族的理解是掠夺性和侵略性的，他将其视为种族之间不断的战争。而丘吉尔则默认，好吧，（我想区别就在于）也许他们会成为相当不错的随从吧。你觉得呢？是的，我认为这非常中肯，汤姆。我认为他有着强烈的贵族义务感。我认为他有一种父权式的心理。有些听众可能会说——而且他们也并非完全错误——他们觉得这种优越感完全、压倒性地令人反感。我想如果你要为他辩护的话——我的意思是，其实用“攻击-辩护”的方式来谈论历史人物本来就毫无意义，但我们不妨沉溺其中一秒钟——你会说，这非常普遍，你知道，当时绝大多数英国人，就像绝大多数法国人、比利时人、德国人或荷兰人一样，都共享这种优越感。
That Hitler's understanding of race is predatory and aggressive, and he sees it as a constant war between races. Churchill kind of assumes that, well, you know, maybe they'd make rather good Batman, I guess would be the difference. Do you think? Yeah, I think that's very fair, Tom. I think he has a strong sense of noblesse oblige. I think he has a sense of paternalism. Some listeners may say, and they're not necessarily wrong, that they find the sense of superiority completely overwhelmingly off-putting. I suppose you would say if you were, I i mean i think actually the sort of attack defense way of talking about people from the past is pointless anyway but that's let's indulge it for a second in his defense you would say um it's very common you know most probably most britains at the time like most frenchmen or indeed belians or Germans or whatever, Dutchmen, shared this sense of, had this sort of sense of superiority.
但基本上，统治一个帝国而不同时在统治阶级中灌输这种优越感是不可能的，因为否则帝国按定义就不过是海市蜃楼。不过，汤姆，我认为他往往表现出攻击性的时候，是在这种优越感受到威胁的时候。换句话说，当人们挑战帝国时——甘地就是两次世界大战之间最著名的例子——丘吉尔经常会——而且他总是诉诸
But basically it's impossible to rule an empire and not have that sense of superiority instilled in the upper classes because otherwise empires are by definition the things of smoke and mirrors. Where he tends to be aggressive, though, Tom, I think is when that is threatened. So in other words, when people challenge the empire, I mean, Gandhi is the most famous example in the interwar years. Churchill will often, and he always reaches
最具情感色彩、最极端、最具有攻击性的修辞，因为这几乎是他作为记者学到的技能，不是吗？他在每一次演讲、每一篇文章中总是言过其实。言过其实是丘吉尔的一种文学本能。这就是为什么我认为你最终常常会发现他说出的话旨在震惊世人、在当时逗人发笑，或者让人写出——你知道——那种几乎是小报风格的东西。我认为这实际上在一定程度上掩盖了他的真实一面，
for the most emotive, extreme, aggressive rhetoric because that's almost the skill he's learned as a journalist, isn't it? He always goes over the top in every speech, every article, to go over the top is Churchill's kind of literary instinct. And so that's why I think you often end up with him saying things that are designed to shock or to make people laugh at the time or to make them write, you know, sort of almost that sort of tabloid style. I think that probably actually belies him to an extent,
因为我认为在内心深处——也许有些听众会说“哦，这只是诡辩”，我不知道——我认为在内心深处，他比他那些更具攻击性的贬低言论所表现出来的要更加善良。是的。我的意思是，他总是信手拈来那些极具情绪化色彩的语言——我敢说——就像一个畅销英国小报里的杰出专栏作家一样。但当然，他最辉煌的时刻是当这种语言的力量与配得上这种语言的对象相遇时。所以，当他谈论希特勒和纳粹时，他的修辞力量拥有足以表达所面对的邪恶规模的威力。显然，当他把这一套用在甘地身上时，那就太荒谬了——我的意思是，这当然
because I think deep down, and maybe some listeners will say, oh, this is just special pleading. I don't know. I think deep down, he's more good natured than some of his more sort of aggressive put downs would lead you to believe. Yes. I mean, he always reaches for the emotive language of, dare I say, a brilliant columnist in a best-selling British tabloid. But of course, his greatest moment is where the force of that language meets with an object that merits that language. So the force of his rhetoric when he's talking about Hitler and the Nazis, it has the power that is able to express the scale of the evil that is being confronted obviously when he's applying it to gandhi it's ridiculous i mean it's well of course
因为我认为从内心深处，也许有些听众会说，哦，这只是诡辩。我不知道。我认为从内心深处，他其实比他那些比较具有攻击性的贬低言论所表现出来的要更善良一些。是的。我的意思是，他总是倾向于使用带有强烈情感色彩的语言，如果我敢这么说的话，就像一个畅销英国小报的才华横溢的专栏作家。但当然，他最辉煌的时刻是当这种语言的力量遇到一个与之相匹配的对象时。因此，当他谈论希特勒和纳粹时，他的修辞力量能够表达出正在对抗的邪恶的规模，而很显然，当他把这种修辞用到甘地身上时，这就很荒谬了，我的意思是，当然
it seemed ludicrous in the 1930s for precisely that reason because in the interwar years churchill had used this incredibly archaic children's storybook kind of language yeah crossed with the tabloid newspaper very aggressive very sort of almost cod Arthurian and people had just thought he was a joke been talking about independence in this way but as you say when he then that that archaic style proves perfect for rallying the nation in 1940 in a way that it didn't talk about complicated issues in the 1930s anyway Dominic we we're not talking about yeah we've got completely gone slatheric, we're not talking about Churchill. Yeah, we've gone completely... We've gone slathering off. We're not talking about Churchill
在20世纪30年代，这种说法看起来荒谬至极，正是因为在两次世界大战之间，丘吉尔使用的这种极其古老的儿童故事书般的语言——是的，夹杂着小报风格，非常具有侵略性，几乎有点像伪亚瑟王传奇——人们当时只是觉得他像个笑话，用这种方式谈论独立。但正如你所说，到了1940年，这种古老的风格却完美地发挥了鼓舞国家的作用，而在30年代，它并不是用来谈论复杂问题的。不管怎样，多米尼克，我们不是在谈论……是的，我们已经完全跑题了，我们不是在谈论丘吉尔。是的，我们已经完全……我们已经扯远了。我们不是在谈论丘吉尔
in the 30s and 40s. We're talking about young Churchill. We should take a break, Tom. So he is now in India. We should take a break. When we come back, we will look at his engagement in two classic imperial adventures,
在30年代和40年代的事情。我们谈论的是年轻的丘吉尔。我们该休息一下了，汤姆。所以他现在在印度。我们该休息一下了。当我们回来时，我们将看看他参与的两场经典的帝国冒险，
a war on the Northwest Frontier and his journey with Kitchener to cartoon. So, uh, we will be discussing that after the break. We'll see you when we come back. Bye. Bye.
西北边境战争以及他随基茨纳前往喀土穆的旅程。所以，呃，我们在休息之后会讨论这个。我们回来时见。再见。再见。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host the rest is entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q and a, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告的音频、收听额外单集并提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are in the middle of the life, the early life of Winston Churchill. Tom, the Indian Northwestern Frontier and Sabindan Blood. It's the most brilliant name, isn't it? Yeah, I mean, only Churchill would have it. Have you seen a picture of him? No, I haven't. He's brilliant. Everything that you would expect with a name like Sabindan Blood.
欢迎回到《历史余音》。我们正置身于温斯顿·丘吉尔的生平之中，也就是他早年的生活。汤姆，印度西北边境和萨宾登·布拉德。这是一个多么出色的名字，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，只有丘吉尔才会拥有它。你见过他的照片吗？不，我没见过。他太棒了。拥有像萨宾登·布拉德这样一个名字，一切都如你所料。
The scale of his moustache, it's the most imperial looking moustache you've ever seen. I highly recommend anyone listening to this, go and look up, go and Google Sabindan Blood. You will not be disappointed at what you find. That's excellent news. So Sabindan Blood is the descendant. But you know, he died aged 98 in 1940. 1940, wow. Yeah, so very long old. So Sir Bindon Blood was the descendant of the Colonel Blood
他那小胡子的规模，简直是你见过最具帝国气派的小胡子。我强烈建议任何收听这个节目的人去查一下，去谷歌搜索一下萨宾登·布拉德。你不会对你的发现感到失望的。真是个好消息。所以萨宾登·布拉德是那个后代。但你知道，他在1940年以98岁高龄去世了。1940年，哇。是的，所以非常长寿。所以爵士平登·布拉德是布拉德上校的后代
who stole the crown jewels. Yeah. It's an uncommon name, isn't it? It's blood. Anyway, Sir Bindon Blood is a commander up in northwestern India. He's, again, yet another crony of Churchill's mother and their sort of posh friends. And Churchill has basically extracted from him a promise that if ever there's a rebellion on the northwest frontier and subdued blood has to put it down, he will let Churchill come with him. Surprise, surprise.
他偷了王冠珠宝。是的。这是一个不常见的名字，对吧？是布拉德。不管怎样，萨宾登·布拉德是印度西北部的一名指挥官。他，同样又是丘吉尔母亲的一个密友，以及他们那种上流社会的朋友。丘吉尔基本上从他那里得到了一个承诺，如果西北边境发生叛乱，且萨宾登·布拉德不得不去平息它，他就会让丘吉尔随行。不出所料。
In August 1897, Churchill hears that the Pashtuns have indeed risen in the incredibly sort of remote valleys on the northwestern frontier of India. So that's what's now Pakistan. Pakistan, sort of Afghan border, I suppose. And Churchill immediately asks Subindan Blood if he can come. At first, Subindan Blood struggles to find a place for him. Churchill gets a job as a war correspondent again. So he's taking leave from his regiment, hasn't he? His regiment.
1897年8月，丘吉尔听说普什图人确实在印度西北边境极其偏远的峡谷中起义了。所以那就是现在的巴基斯坦。巴基斯坦，我想大概是阿富汗边境。丘吉尔立即询问萨宾登·布拉德他是否可以前往。起初，萨宾登·布拉德很难为他找到一个位置。丘吉尔再次找到了一份战地记者的工作。所以他是从他的团里请假对吧？他的团。
His mother yet again pulls some strings and arranges that some of his letters from the front will be published in the Daily Telegraph. They'll pay him £5 a time, which is good money in those days. And off goes Churchill to the northwest frontier to serve with Sir Bindon Blood and the
他的母亲再次动用了一些关系，安排将他从前线发回的一些信件发表在《每日电讯报》上。他们每次付给他5英镑，在当时这可是笔不错的收入。于是丘吉尔出发前往西北边境，与萨宾登·布拉德以及
12,000 strong Malacan Field Force. So they're basically it's a punitive expedition to deal with these tribes that have been sort of robbing villages and just sort of in church as churchill would no doubt say making a nuisance of themselves yeah um and he in classic churchill style he describes the whole thing as this is the most tremendous laugh doesn't he so he says at one point they go with all these political officers and the political officers are constantly trying to sort of do deals with the tribesmen and none and churchill and his pals are aghast at this behavior because they just
拥有12000名士兵的马拉坎野战部队。所以他们基本上这是一场惩罚性远征，为了对付那些一直在掠夺村庄的部落，正如丘吉尔毫无疑问会说的那样，他们在那里自找麻烦。是的，呃，他以典型的丘吉尔风格，把整件事描述为这简直是莫大的笑话，不是吗？所以他在某个时刻说，他们带着所有这些政治官员一起去，而政治官员们不断地试图与部落成员达成某种交易，然而丘吉尔和他的伙伴们对这种行为感到震惊，因为他们只是
want to have a huge fight and to his delight they do have a fight he says it was all very exciting and for those who did not get killed or hurt very jolly well yeah so a lot of people were killed on our side their widows have had to be pensioned by the imperial government and others were badly wounded and hopped around for the rest of their lives yeah yeah he thinks the whole thing is the most tremendous fun like most young fools i was looking for trouble and i hope that something exciting would happen it did big exclamation mark yeah but he but the funny thing about churchill when he describes this because the passages in about Churchill when he describes this, because the passages in his book about, I mean,
想要痛痛快快地打一仗，令他高兴的是，他们真的打了一仗。他说这一切非常刺激，对于那些没有被杀或受伤的人来说，真是太棒了。是的，所以我们这边有很多人丧生，他们的遗孀不得不靠帝国政府发给抚恤金，其他人则身受重伤，在余生中一瘸一拐地活着。是的，是的，他认为整件事简直是无比的欢乐。像大多数年轻的傻瓜一样，我当时在寻找麻烦，我希望发生一些刺激的事情。结果真的发生了，一个巨大的感叹号！是的，但是他——但丘吉尔在描述这一幕时有趣的地方在于，因为书中关于丘吉尔的段落——我的意思是，
this is a tiny war by British imperial standards. It's barely even a war. It's just a sort of raid, a raid and the repression of a raid. The funny thing is that on the one hand, he talks about it in this sort of this enjoyable skirmish crackled away, you know, this great, great, great fun. And yet at the same time, he say a few lines later he will say one man was shot through the breast and pouring with blood another lay on his back kicking and twisting the british officer was spinning around just
按英国标准的帝国规模来看，这是一场微不足道的战争。这甚至算不上是一场战争。它只是一种突袭，一场突袭和对突袭的镇压。有趣的是，一方面，他用这种令人愉快的、噼啪作响的小冲突来形容它，你知道，这真是太棒太棒太棒的乐事了。然而与此同时，几行之后他又会说，一个人胸部中弹，鲜血直流，另一个人仰面躺着，双腿抽搐扭曲，一个英国军官就在我身后转着圈子，他的脸血肉模糊，右眼被挖了出来。是的，这当然是一次冒险，而在结局的时候，究竟是否值得，我无从得知。无论如何，在两周结束时，山谷变成了一片沙漠，荣誉得到了满足。呃，你知道，这里有一个塔西佗的回应痕迹，那种认为，是的，你知道的，他们制造了一片沙漠，却称之为和平，称之为和平。嗯，是的，他在开头说，他其实认为英国人，你知道的，根本不应该费心去搞这一切，他为西北边境的部落感到难过。
behind me his face a mass of blood his right eye cut out yes it was certainly an adventure and and at the end of the cap whether it was worth it i cannot tell at any rate at the end of a fortnight the valley was a desert and honor was satisfied uh you know and that leaving there's an echo of tacitus there the idea that yeah you know they created desert and called it peace call it peace um yeah and he says at the beginning he says that he doesn't actually think the British, you know, should have even bothered with all this, that he feels sorry for the tribesmen of the Northwest Frontier.
他某种程度上很钦佩他们。他认为他们不应该受到惩罚。所以他有这种奇怪的、存在一种奇怪的模棱两可，让我想起，这真是一个非常奇特的比较，让我想起了一点点《弗莱什曼历险记》。所以在《弗莱什曼历险记》中，弗莱什曼，他的一部分总是感到害怕并逃跑，而丘吉尔从未这样做过。
He kind of admires them. He doesn't think they should have been punished. So he has this weird, there's this strange ambiguity that reminds me, and this is such a peculiar comparison, it reminds me a tiny bit of the Flashman novels. So in the Flashman novels, Flashman, there's part of him that is always frightened and running away, which Churchill never does.
但他的另一部分热爱所有这些冒险，热爱那种浪漫色彩。然而与此同时，他又意识到了他所做事情的那种伪善和道德上的模棱两可。我想，丘吉尔身上确实有那么一点这种感觉，他知道——他内心的一部分知道这很可怕，人们正在遭受
But there's part of him that loves all these adventures and loves the kind of romance of it. And yet at the same time, he's aware of the sort of hypocrisies and the moral ambiguity of what he's doing. And there's a little bit of a sense of that, I think, with Churchill, that he knows that there's part of him that knows that this is horrible, that people are being
可怕的伤害和杀戮。他以这种滑稽的方式来书写它，但这种幽默源于这样一个事实，即人们已经死亡或被残酷地致残。是的。而且我认为，但同时这也有一种达尔文主义的意味，即这就是强者所做的事，这就是生活本来的样子。然而与此同时，他又会提到他的朋友威廉·布朗·克莱顿中尉在担架上被活活砍成碎块。他对他的母亲说，他哭了。丘吉尔看到他的朋友时哭了。所以并不是说他铁石心肠。
horribly injured and killed. He writes about it in this comical way, but the humour of it derives from the fact that people have died or been maimed. Yeah. And I think, but also there is a kind of Darwinian sense that this is just what the strong do, just the way life is. And yet at the same time, he'll say that his friend, Lieutenant William Brown Clayton, was literally cut to pieces on a stretcher. And he says to his mother, he says, he cried. Churchill cried as he saw his friend. So it's not that he's unfeeling.
或许他只是认为世界就是一个……嗯，我认为他的反应体现在许多层面上，不是吗？所以有我们谈论过的那种感伤，以及能够非常、非常深刻地感受到悲伤的能力——感伤或许是一个不准确的词——那种兴奋感，这简直是太棒的乐趣；一种达尔文主义的观点，认为世界本来就是如此，过去如此，将来也一直会如此；或许还有一点遗憾，那就是英国人的表现并没有他们表现出来的那么好；我认为这方面的证据体现在他对他的下一次冒险中发生的事情的反应上，也就是苏丹战争。所以这真的是一场终结所有帝国冒险的帝国冒险。所以经常收听节目的听客们会听过
It's that maybe he just thinks the world is a place where... Well, I think his response is operating on many levels isn't it so there's the sentimentality that we've talked about the and the ability to feel grief sentimental is perhaps an unfair word ability to feel grief very very deeply a sense of excitement this is all tremendous fun a darwinian sense that it's just the way that the world is it always has been it always will be and perhaps uh a slight ache that that the british are not behaving better than they are behaving uh and i think that the evidence for that is in his response to what happens in his next adventure which is uh the sudan war so this really is the imperial adventure to end all imperial adventures so regular listeners will have listened
我们关于戈登将军及其在苏丹的冒险经历的播客，我认为可以公平地说，那次经历以非常糟糕的结局告终。戈登将军在喀土穆的官邸中，被马赫迪的起义伊斯兰军队杀死。马赫迪是一个自封的弥赛亚，他领导苏丹人民掀起了对埃及以及埃及的帝国赞助者英国的浩大起义。因此戈登在1885年被杀，这给英国公众留下了深刻的印象。我的意思是，这确实
to our podcast about general gordon and his adventures in the Sudan, which had ended, I think it's fair to say, very badly, with General Gordon being killed in the residency in Khartoum by the insurgent kind of Islamist army of the Mahdi, who was this sort of self-appointed messiah who had led the people of of the sudan and this tremendous uprising against egypt and against egypt's kind of imperial sponsor britain so gordon had been killed in 1885 and that had left a tremendous impression on the british public i mean it really
是一种持续的痛处，是一场必须被复仇的惨败。自那以后，十多年来，人们一直渴望彻底清算，对象不是马赫迪，因为马赫迪已经死了，而是他的继任者，被称为哈里发的人。他统治着现在苏丹、南苏丹以及埃塞俄比亚的一些地方。基本上在1898年，这达到了白热化。对维多利亚时代的人来说无论如何都是伟大的帝国英雄，赫伯特·基奇纳爵士率领着这支两万人的部队向南进发。我的意思是，这（应用……）你知道的，这就是那种典型的帝国冒险。丘吉尔再次听说这件事正在发生，并且
was the kind of the running sore the uh the terrible defeat that must be avenged and there was ever since that for more than 10 years there had been this thirst for a final settling of accounts not with the mardi because the mardi had died but with his successor who was called the khalifa um who ruled what is now sudan and south sudan some bits of ethiopia and basically in 1898 this came to a head um the great imperial hero to the victorians anyway sir herbert kitchener is leading this force of 20 000 men south i mean this app you know it's the it's the sort of paradigmatic imperial adventure and once again churchill hears that it's happening and is
渴望前往。他试图让母亲去走后门，试图让首相索尔兹伯里勋爵去走后门。基奇纳不想让他在那里，他们之间有一场持续余生的宿怨。就在他书中的这个地方，我太喜欢这个段落了，汤姆。丘吉尔不断申请前往，而人们不断阻挠他，因为很显然在这个阶段他已经有了名气。是的，有这种自以为是、爱出风头的奖章猎人。奖章猎人，他说，我现在察觉到，有许多消息闭塞、心怀叵测的人，对我的活动并没有采取赞赏的态度。他是怎么说的？
desperate to go tries to get his mother to pull strings he tries to get lord salisbury the prime minister to pull strings kitchener doesn't want him there um and they have a feud that lasts for the rest of their lives and it's at this point in his book i love this this passage tom churchill keeps applying to go and people keep blocking him because clearly at this stage he's already got a reputation yeah there's this sort of bumptious toe rack metal hunter a metal hunter he says i now perceive that there were many ill-informed and ill-disposed people who did not take a favourable view of my activities. What does he say?
这个词是奖章猎人。有时在一些高层和低层的军事圈子里，会使用诸如“自我宣传者”之类的词，这种方式我相信会让这些笔记的读者感到惊讶和痛苦。感到震惊。他说，出于一种最奇怪、甚至难以解释的巧合，类似的指责总是出现在
The expression is medal hunter. A self-advertiser were used from time to time in some high and low military circles in a manner which would, I am sure, surprise and pain the readers of these notes. Astonished. He says, by a most curious and indeed unaccountable coincidence, similar accusations have always presented themselves
我无辜的足迹之后。我想这也是丘吉尔讨人喜欢的地方之一。他知道自己是一个寻求关注的人，非常自以为是之类。而且他对于别人也是这样感到滑稽。我认为正是这种幽默感，他能够对自己的滑稽的态度，使他比他原本可能展现出的样子要更讨人喜欢。
in the wake of my innocent footsteps. And I think that's one of the things about Churchill's lovability. He knows that he's an attention seeker and terribly bumptious and stuff. And he's funny about the fact that other people are. I think it's the sense of humor, the fact that he's able to be funny about himself that makes him more endearing than he might otherwise um that he might otherwise be but anyway he gets it doesn't he he pulls he pulls his strings and he's after he's after after the sedan as is the um as is classic churchill he he's also writing a column at the time so he's going to write for the morning post 15 pounds per column three times what he was paid in india uh he has
他原本可能展现出的样子。但无论怎样，他还是做到了，不是吗？他动用了关系，他正追寻着……追寻着苏丹，正如……正如典型的丘吉尔那样，他当时也在写专栏，所以他将为《晨邮报》写作，每个专栏15英镑，是他在印度时报酬的三倍。他出发前
dinner before he goes with the head of the psychical research society and they make him promised that if he's killed he will communicate with them from death i'd imagine um churchill so off he goes and, if you ever doubted that Churchill was a wonderful writer, because of course, his great Second World War books, you know, there was an enormous number of collaborators with him on that.
与心理研究学会的负责人共进晚餐，他们让他承诺，如果他阵亡了，他将从死后与他们进行交流。我想象一下……丘吉尔就这样出发了。如果你曾怀疑丘吉尔是否是一位出色的作家，因为当然了，他那部伟大的第二次世界大战著作，你知道，有大量的人与他合作完成。
And that sort of suspicion that there's an awful lot of ghostwriting hung over his subsequent Nobel Prize for Literature. But the way he, his descriptions of the lead up to the Battle of Omdurman are incredibly evocative. So he goes across the desert from Cairo. literature but his the way he his descriptions of the lead-up to the battle of omdurman are
这种怀疑——即有大量的代笔——笼罩了他随后的诺贝尔文学奖。但他写作的方式，他对奥姆杜尔曼战役前夕的描述，具有令人难以置信的唤起力。所以他从开罗穿过沙漠。文学，但他——他——他对奥姆杜尔曼战役前夕的描述是
incredibly evocative so he goes across the desert from cairo i mean a classic churchill he gets lost in the desert he spends a night without food and water and has to wander for 70 miles before he rediscovers the convoy but again that's barely even that happens in sort of half a sentence yeah as you say i mean if we did that that would be the we'd never forget it you'd never talk of anything else if that happened to you that sort of happens to him just fleetingly on the way they arrive the anglo-egyptian army have almost reached khartoum they're in this place called omdurman uh there's 25 000 of them there's a colossal army of what are called the dervishes so this is the calhalifa's men the
令人难以置信的充满画面感。所以他穿过了开罗的沙漠。我的意思是，典型的丘吉尔，他在沙漠中迷路了，他度过了一个没有食物和水的夜晚，不得不徘徊了70英里才重新找到车队。但再次强调，这甚至只发生在大半句话里。是的，正如你所说，我的意思是，如果我们经历了那种事，那将是——我们永远不会忘记。如果你经历了那种事，你将永远不会谈论别的事情。那件事就这样轻描淡写地发生在他身上，在他前行的路上。他们到达时，英埃联军几乎已经到达喀土穆，他们在一个叫做奥姆杜尔曼的地方。
sort of the islamist kind of tribesmen who are you know they there's a massive disparity one of the great disparities ever in terms of technology and weaponry because we have got the gatling gun yeah they have not but it's a maxim i think omdurman the machine guns and i think there are 50 of them. The dervishes obviously think this will be a classic battle in which they will sort of, you know, ride into action and wave their swords and rifles will sing out. And they're not really prepared for the machine guns. Industrial slaughter. Industrial slaughter.
那里有25000人，还有一支庞大的被称为“德尔维希人”的军队。所以这是哈里发的部下，也就是那种伊斯兰部落成员。你知道，他们之间存在巨大的悬殊，在科技和武器方面可以说是历史上差距最大的一次，因为我们有加特林机枪——是的，他们没有。但我想那是马克沁机枪，奥姆杜尔曼战役中的机枪，我想有50挺。德尔维希人显然认为这将是一场经典的战斗，他们会以某种方式冲进战场，挥舞着宝枪，步枪会鸣响。而他们并没有真正为机枪做好准备。工业化屠杀。工业化屠杀。
I mean, Churchill, the way he describes this, you know, nothing like the Battle of Omdurman will ever be seen again. It was the last link in the long chain of those spectacular conflicts whose vivid and majestic splendor has done so much to invest war with glamour. So on the one hand, he sees this as the ultimate. I mean, this is the culmination. This is really, talking about that sense of destiny, this is the moment he has dreamed of since he was a boy. And as you say, his prose is so over over all the immense dome of the sky done to turquoise turquoise to deepest blue pierced by the flaming sun weighed hard and heavy on marching necks and shoulders i mean so good yeah so it's a it's
我的意思是，丘吉尔对这一幕的描述，你知道，再也不会见到类似奥姆杜尔曼战役的场景了。它是长串壮观冲突中的最后一环，这些冲突生动而雄伟的光辉极大地赋予了战争以魅力。所以一方面，他将此视为终极。我的意思是，这是最高潮。这真的是，谈到那种命运感，这就是他从小就梦寐以求的时刻。正如你所说，他的散文是如此……在天空那巨大的穹顶上，从绿松石色变成最深的蓝色，被炽热的太阳刺破，沉重地压在行军的脖子和肩膀上。我的意思是太棒了。是的，所以这是
fantastically readable this sort of sense he absolutely has a sense that this is a moment of supreme imperial melodrama that he's been dreaming of since a moment of history isn't it because he recognizes that cavalry charges and men with spears and you know this is an ancient ancient story that perhaps is this is the last manifestation of it it's last time it ever happens and he's really conscious of that he um i forgot to mention he's traveled with all ever happens and he's really conscious of that he um i forgot to mention he's traveled with all the champagne and he has a lot of champagne with uh an officer commanding a gunboat called lieutenant david beatty and beatty is going to be one of the key
极其具有可读性。这种感觉，他绝对有一种感觉，这是他一直梦想着的至高无上的帝国情节的时刻。这是一个历史时刻，不是吗？因为他认识到骑兵冲锋和拿着长矛的人，你知道，这是一个古老古老的故事，也许这是它最后的表现形式，这是它最后一次发生，他对此有着深刻的意识。他……我忘了提，他随身携带了所有的
people in the first world war the battle of jutland so again one of these characters who will then pop up pops up yeah later on but dawn rises on the 2nd of September, 1898. And Churchill has this fantastic lyrical description of the dawn and the sense of tension and the sun rising over the desert. And he hears the noise of people coming towards him. He says, what is this sound which we hear? A deadened roar coming up to us in waves. They are cheering for God, his prophet and his holy khalifa they think they are going to win talk of fun where will you beat this i mean that's obviously not what a lot of the british soldiers yeah nothing they must have been absolutely terrified yeah and then there's this moment of i mean it really is the sort of the textbook clash of ancients and modern
香槟，他和一艘名为“大卫·贝蒂中尉”的炮舰的指挥官一起喝了很多香槟，贝蒂将成为第一次世界大战日德兰海战中的关键人物之一。所以再次说明，这些角色随后会涌现出来，是的，后来又出现了。然而，1898年9月2日的黎明降临了。丘吉尔对黎明以及那种紧张感和阳光升起照耀沙漠的景象有着极好、极具抒情色彩的描写。他听到有人向他走来的声音。他说，我们听到的这个声音是什么？一阵沉闷的轰鸣声向我们涌来。他们正在为上帝、他的先知和神圣的哈里发欢呼。他们认为他们会赢。说到乐趣，你在哪里能找到比这更好的？我的意思是，这显然不是许多英国士兵的想法。是的，他们当时一定吓坏了。
where he and his, they ride into, the guns are singing out, the machine guns are beginning to rattle. But Churchill and the 21st Lancers launched this charge, the largest British cavalry charge since the Crimea, really the last great cavalry charge in all British history. Churchill has a troop of 25 men.
然后是这样一个时刻——这确实是古代与现代的教科书式冲突——他同伴们骑马冲了进去，枪声大作，机枪开始噼啪作响。但丘吉尔和第21枪骑兵团发动了冲锋，这是自克里米亚战争以来英国最大规模的骑兵冲锋，实际上也是英国历史上最后一次伟大的骑兵冲锋。丘吉尔率领着一个由25人组成的小分队。
He's on this Arab pony. He's got his, because of his arm, he's got his pistol, his Mauser, and they're right down into this water course, and there are sort of dervishes looming up out of the scrub, and he is firing away with his revolver, and men are falling all around him, this kind of swords flashing. It is the most incredible swashbuckling scene. But in due course he when he looks at
他骑着这匹阿拉伯小马。因为他的胳膊受伤了，他拿着手枪，他的毛瑟手枪，他们直接冲进了河道，灌木丛中隐现着德尔维希人的身影，他用左轮手枪连连开火，周围的人纷纷倒下，剑光闪烁。这是最不可思议、最惊险刺激的场面。但在适当的时候，当他看到
the industrial scale of the slaughter and the disparity he pays due tribute to the courage of the men that that the british have been fighting yeah so he says the discipline and machinery triumphed over the most desperate valor and after And after an enormous carnage, certainly exceeding 20,000 men who strewed the ground in heaps and swathes like snowdrifts, the whole mass of the dervishes dissolved into fragments and into particles and streamed away into the fantastic mirages of the desert. These were as brave men as ever walked the earth, destroyed, not conquered by machinery. So this is not a kind of, he's not exalting in the slaughter. The battle is one of the high points, probably the high point of his life. The moment he's been dreaming of, the
工业化规模的屠杀和悬殊的差距时，他向英国人一直在与之战斗的人们的勇气致以应有的敬意。是的，他说，纪律和机械战胜了最绝望的勇敢。在经历了一场巨大的大屠杀之后，死伤人数肯定超过了20000人，他们横七竖八地倒在地上，尸横遍野，堆积如山，如同雪堆一般，整个德尔维希人的大军瓦解成碎片和颗粒，消散在沙漠荒诞的海市蜃楼中。这些人是有史以来最勇敢的人，他们是被机械摧毁的，而不是被征服的。所以这不是一种……他并没有为这场屠杀而欢欣鼓舞。这场战斗是他一生的最高点之一，很可能是最高点。他一直梦想的时刻，
exhilaration and the adrenaline of the cavalry charge. And he loves fighting the dervishes, but he sees them as noble, admirable even adversaries who've been cut down by machinery. And he feels very conflicted about that. And he specifically, he, it does, Kitchener's victory does nothing to reconcile Churchill to Kitchener as a moral figure. He despises Kitchener. Kitchener is a very austere man.
骑兵冲锋的兴奋与肾上腺素飙升。他喜欢与德尔维希人作战，但他认为他们是高尚的、甚至令人钦佩的对手，却被机械无情地砍倒。他对此感到十分矛盾。他明确地——基奇纳的胜利并没有让丘吉尔将基奇纳视为一个道德人物。他鄙视基奇纳。基奇纳是一个非常严厉的人。
And the sort of, Kitchener is your sort of exhibit A in your sort of unsmiling, pith-helmeted, deeply repressed sort of British Imperial officer, isn't he? Sort of strange associations with young boys. Utterly unsparing, no mercy. And with a real streak of cruelty, I think. Well, so Kitchener orders that the Mahdi's tomb, because the Mahdi's already dead,
那种……基奇纳就是你那种不苟言笑、戴着遮阳帽、深深压抑着的英国帝国军官的典型代表，不是吗？跟年轻男孩之间有一些奇怪的交往。冷酷无情，毫不留情。而且我认为，带有真正残忍的特质。嗯，所以基奇纳下令将马赫迪的陵墓——因为马赫迪已经死了——
that the Mahdi's tomb in revenge for General Gordon, the Mahdi's tomb is desecrated and is is blown up uh but he then he demands that the mardy's head is is saved and he um keeps it in a kerosene tin although churchill says he pretended to have it in a kerosene tin but the tin may have contained anything perhaps ham sandwiches. Yeah. Very Churchillian detail. But Churchill is outraged by this. He thinks it's incredibly unsporting. He's also outraged by the treatment of captured dervishes after the battle. So this
为了报复戈登将军，马赫迪的陵墓被亵渎并被炸毁。但随后他要求将马赫迪的头颅保留下来，他把它放在一个煤油罐里，尽管丘吉尔说他假装把它放在煤油罐里，但罐子里可能装了任何东西，也许是火腿三明治。是的，非常丘吉尔式的细节。但丘吉尔对此感到愤怒。他认为这极其不够体育精神。他对战后被俘的德尔维希人的待遇也感到愤怒。所以这
is the classic example of Churchill's sort of sense of that everything is a game, but because it's a game, because it's a sporting encounter, you shake hands afterwards. So he says afterwards that he's seen people
是丘吉尔那种观念的典型例子：一切都是一场游戏，但正因为这是一场游戏，因为这是一场体育竞技，所以赛后你要握手言和。所以他事后说，他看到有人
killing dervish prisoners after the battle. He writes to his cousin, the Duke of Marlborough, the general callousness which he, Kitchener, has repeatedly exhibited has disgusted me. I have seen acts of great barbarity perpetuated at Omdurman and I have been thoroughly sickened of human blood.
在战后杀害德尔维希战俘。他写信给他的表弟马尔罗公爵：他（基奇纳）一再表现出的普遍冷酷无情让我感到恶心。我在奥姆杜尔曼目睹了极为野蛮的暴行，我对人类的鲜血感到彻底的作呕。
I should always be glad that I was one of those who took these brave men on with weapons, little better than theirs, who would only add discipline to back against their numbers. All the rest of the army merely fed out death by machinery. Yeah. And he calls Kitchener utterly callous. Yeah.
我将永远庆幸自己是那些与这些勇敢的人战斗的人之一，他们使用的武器只比他们好一点点，他们只是用纪律来对抗对方的人数。军队的其他所有人只不过是在用机器源源不断地送命。是的。他称基奇纳极其冷酷。是的。
Which I think is a very fair description. Yeah. Well, I mean, Kitchener was, Kitchener was ruthless. As we will see when we come to the burr war yeah kitchener was absolutely ruthless and said i've got a job to do i'm going to do it and that's to kill as many dervishes as possible churchill is horrified about that because if you have this sense that everything is treasure island
我认为这是一个非常恰当的描述。是的。好吧，我的意思是，基奇纳是——基奇纳是冷酷无章的。正如我们在讲到布尔战争时将要看到的，基奇纳绝对是冷酷无情，并说：“我有一项工作要做，我打算把它完成，那就是尽可能多地杀死德尔维希人。”丘吉尔对此感到惊恐，因为如果你有这样一种感觉，认为一切都是《金银岛》
and everything is king solomon's minds then as it were the sort of what you might see as one of the more admirable sides of that because of course they're less admirable sides but one of the more admirable sides is you think of your opponents as jolly brave you you almost romanticized sentimentalize your adversaries which churchill definitely well churchill's harrow they would be eaten yeah that's how he thinks yeah um so on the way home, one nice detail that I thought you would appreciate. I'm sorry that you haven't brought it up yourself is that Churchill makes friends with the most brilliant man in journalism I have ever met,
一切都是《所罗门王的宝藏》，那么，人们可能认为这是其中较为令人钦佩的一面——因为当然还有不太令人钦佩的一面——但其中较为令人钦佩的一面是，你认为你的对手是非常勇敢的，你几乎把你的对手浪漫化、感伤化了，而丘吉尔绝对……好吧，丘吉尔在哈罗公学……他们会被吃掉的。是的，他就是这么想的。嗯，所以在回家的路上，有一个很好的细节，我想你会感激的。我很抱歉你没有自己提出来，那就是丘吉尔与我见过的报业中最杰出的人交了朋友，
who is the star writer of a new newspaper. You know, the newspaper in question, Tom, you do know, you just don't want to say, you just don't want to say, I can't. So't so uh he would
他是新报纸的王牌作家。你知道是哪份报纸，汤姆，你其实知道，你只是不想说，你只是不想说，我不能。所以，呃，他会
it be the daily mail he writes friends with gw stevens the star writer of her majesty's as it then was daily mail um he churchill lends him a piece of paper so that stevens can write a dispatch about the war for the readers of the mail when churchill comes down, he says, I found that all he'd written on my nice sheet of paper was pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, bang. And Churchill was disgusted at this. That's the day he mailed on it. But then he says, Tom, he says, Stevens had many other styles besides that of the jaunty,
是《每日邮报》吗？他与当时女王陛下的《每日邮报》的王牌作家G·W·斯蒂文斯交了朋友。丘吉尔借给他一张纸，以便斯蒂文斯能为《邮报》的读者写一篇关于战争的电讯。当丘吉尔走下来时，他说，我发现他在我漂亮的纸上写的东西只有：砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、轰。丘吉尔对此感到厌恶。那是《每日邮报》上的报道。但接着他说，汤姆，他说，斯蒂文斯除了那些为《每日邮报》撰写的轻松、轻快、粗制滥造的作品之外，还有许多其他的风格。他发现斯蒂文斯写了一篇关于大英帝国未来的长篇大文章，在这篇文章中，他被誉为新的吉本。哇。好吧，你能想象到吗？想想看。这种事现在永远不会发生了。
breezy, slapdash productions which he wrote for the Daily Mail. He finds that Stevens has written an enormous article about the future of the British Empire in which he has been credited as the new Gibbon. Wow. Well, can you imagine of that? Think of that. That kind of thing would never happen now.
一个历史学家以草率的方式写作，但同时又成了新的吉本。简直无法想象。不，我可以想象你会的。所以多米尼克，是的，这是一个非常重要的细节。我很高兴你把这个加进去了，但我认为这可能是一个很好的结束语，因为本质上，你知道，苏丹战争的故事就是毫不费力的英国优越性，基本上是军事优越性。
A historian writing in a slapdash way, but also being the new Gibbon. Can't think. No, I can imagine you would. So Dominic, yes, that's a very important detail. I'm glad you got that in but i think this is probably a good note on which to end because essentially you know the narrative of um of the sudan war is effortless british superiority essentially military superiority
这种假设是，他们可以参战，他们可以利用他们的工业实力、他们的军事威望，基本上粉碎任何反对他们的人，耀武扬威，随心所欲。这确实不是作为一场冒险的帝国主义，而是一个更具掠夺性和谋杀性的东西。我想，这是一台势不可挡的机器。一台势不可挡的机器，也是让我们称之为“年轻的丘吉尔”的这一系列在各种帝国战争中的冒险经历的最终阶段，我们将在第三部分中探讨，那是所有故事中最非凡的故事。那是所有故事中最非凡的故事，而且它基本上是一场对英国来说极其尴尬的战争。英国的表现非常糟糕。我的意思是，人们可能认为英国表现得很糟糕。
uh the assumption that they can go to war, that they can use their industrial heft, their military prowess, essentially to pulverize anyone who opposes them, throw their weight around, do what they like. And this is imperialism really not as an adventure, but as something altogether more predatory and murderous. It's a juggernaut, I suppose. A juggernaut and the final stage of let's call it young churchill this sequence of adventures uh in various imperial wars uh we'll cover in part three and that's the most extraordinary story of all and that's the most extraordinary story of all and it's it's basically it's a war that is a huge embarrassment to Britain. Britain behaves very badly. I mean, people may think Britain's behaving badly.
这太严厉了，汤姆。我不同意这里的任何说法。它的表现确实非常糟糕。假新闻。多米尼克，不，多米尼克。英国在南非的表现确实非常、非常糟糕，表现得很差劲。在布尔战争中，甚至有那么一个时刻，英国人得到的几乎唯一的好消息都是由温斯顿·丘吉尔提供的，他曾被俘虏然后又逃跑了。这是英国帝国历史上最具戏剧性的惊险刺激的插曲之一。
This is very harsh, Tom. I don't agree with any of this. It behaves very badly. Fake news. Dominic, no, Dominic. Britain does behave very, very badly in South Africa and behaves very poorly. And there is a point in the Burr War where almost the only good news that the British are getting is provided by Winston Churchill, who has been taken prisoner and then escapes. One of the most dramatic episodes of Daring Do in British imperial history.
这将是我们明天节目的主题。但在那之前，为了在汤姆·霍兰德那令人震惊的不爱国结尾之后净化听众的口味，我认为我们应该读一点诗歌，汤姆。我们在这些节目中还没有读过诗歌呢。现在，经常收听《历史余音》的听众会知道，我们是威廉·麦哥纳高尔诗歌的超级崇拜者，他是世界上最糟糕的诗人，他当然写过一首关于泰桥灾难的诗，我们在播客中朗读过，而且我想他也写过一首诗，对吧，关于戈登将军之死的诗，汤姆？他写过。我们为此引用过他的诗。所以我想朗读麦哥纳高尔对奥姆杜尔曼战役的看法，
And that will be the subject of our episode tomorrow. But before that, to cleanse people's palates after that shockingly unpatriotic ending from Tom Holland, I think we should have a bit of poetry, Tom. We haven't had any poetry in these episodes. Now, regular listeners to the rest of this history will know that we are great admirers of the poetry of William McGonagall, the world's worst poet, who of course wrote a poem about the Tay Bridge disaster, which we read out on this podcast, and I think also wrote a poem, didn't he, about the death of General Gordon, Tom? He did. We quoted him for that. So I think I would like to read what McGonagall had to say about the Battle of Omdurman,
因为这是美丽的诗篇：“那是1898年，在9月2日这一天，哈里发和他的幸存随从将长久铭记在心，因为赫伯特·基奇纳爵士在奥姆杜尔曼的战斗中，通过英国军队和苏丹军队彻底消灭了他们。这场战斗中的主要英雄是第21枪骑兵团。他们伴随着嘹亮的欢呼声向敌人发起了辉煌的冲锋，他们的长枪刺穿了黝黑勇士们的身体，使他们许多人不得不舔食尘土。当哈里发看到他高贵的军队被消灭时，他愤怒而悲伤地懊恼与皱眉。于是他策动他高贵的战马，它飞速奔跑，同时他内心对自己呼喊：
because this is beautiful poetry. "'Twas the year of 1898, and on the 2nd of September, which the Khalifa and his surviving followers will long remember, because Sir Herbert Kitchener has annihilated them outright by the British troops and Sudanese in the Omdurman fight. The chief heroes in this fight were the 21st Lancers. They made a brilliant charge on the enemy with ringing cheers, and through the dusky warriors' bodies their lances they did thrust, whereby many of them were made to lick the dust. And when the Khalifa saw his noble army cut down, with rage and grief he did fret and frown. Then he spurred his noble steed, and swiftly it ran, while inwardly to himself he cried,
‘有本事就来抓我呀！’而马赫迪主义现在遭受了沉重打击，因为哈里发和他的追随者遭遇了彻底的覆灭，基督的好仆人戈登将军已经复仇，通过在奥姆杜尔曼战役中击败哈里发。再见。拜拜。感谢收听《历史余音》。想要收听独家单集、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
Catch me if you can! And Mardism now has received a crushing blow, for the Khalifa and his followers have met with a complete overthrow, and General Gordon has been avenged, the good Christian, by the defeat of the Khalifa at the Battle of Omdurman. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集和提前获得现场门票，请访问 TheRestIsEntertainment.com。那就是 TheRestIsEntertainment.com。该剧集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
That's restishistorypod.com I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to TheRestIsEntertainment.com. That's TheRestIsEntertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
That's restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及优先购买现场门票的权益，请访问 TheRestIsEntertainment.com。即 TheRestIsEntertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。